[Music]
and welcome back everybody we're
continuing our coverage in Laredo Texas
as week two kicks off in the capital
murder trial of Ronald Burgos Aviles who
went by his middle name Anthony he's the
former border patrol agent accused of
killing his mistress and young son over
child support money five years ago 28
year old Griselda Hernandez served the
defendant child support documents at his
workplace that child Dominic was a
result of Burgos avilas having an affair
as he lived with his wife and their
children and one month later prosecutors
accuse him of stabbing Hernandez and
their nearly two-year-old son to death
during a planned meet up near a park all
in an effort to avoid consequences for
his infidelity last week ended with half
of the defendant's police interview
being played on the day of the murders
he called 911 at the scene and said he
found the victims already deceased the
police interview concluded on Wednesday
and detectives got him to admit that he
tampered with the crime scene and
predict how a jury would decide his case
check it out
he accepted
somebody else
and then weight loss
[Music]
and papers for child support
okay and what was this of
of my knowledge again not only you said
here
[Music]
you see what I'm saying now
that's all you do is
because the truth is the truth
you'll stick to it all the time
[Music]
is taking
pretty much sourced
Brian call me crazy but that police
interrogation doesn't really look good
for the defendant I imagine he's gonna
have to take the stand to explain all
this right
I would say maybe because at least right
now it looks really really bad when it
comes to the tampering with evidence
chart now in Texas that's two to ten
years what he could possibly do is go up
there and explain himself as to what
this interaction was about but here he's
not really incriminating himself as to
the murders those are the bigger charges
so the question becomes do you want to
go up on the stand to try to protect
yourself from a tampering charge but
only have yourself tied up in terms of a
murder charge because if you omit to the
larger charge no one's going to care
about the tampering so right now I say
it's bad but better to go down on a
tampering charge than testify and go
down on a murder yeah that's a
definitely a good point I wonder if
they're advising him that um well Terry
I want to talk about something else
because talk about something else the
detectives who are interviewed the
defendant he testified in court for a
second day can you tell us what he found
out about the defendant squad car well
the odd thing is Jesse they found a
number of items inside that car first of
all they found what's called a belt
keeper and that is a leather strap that
goes around the duty belt and the
trouser belt just to keep it secure well
there was blood on there why is there
blood on there particularly if he's just
coming across the scene there shouldn't
be any blood on there they also found
blood flakes on that car and they found
blood droplets on that car that too is
really important because it was inside
the car none of the blood should be
inside the car here's the other thing
two telephones and the telephones were
the victims and also of baby Dominic why
are those phones in his car if he had
nothing to do with the killings if he's
just coming across those bodies so very
incriminating evidence indeed inside his
vehicle we were just showing that video
of him maybe wiping something off of his
clothes so investigators wouldn't find
it it's kind of adding up not looking so
great for him but you know him
testifying will that change the game
when we come back two couples go to the
movies to see the romantic comedy no
hard feelings but inside that New Mexico
movie theater a man was shot dead the
dispute that police say started the
whole thing that's next
foreign
[Music]
Albuquerque New Mexico where one man is
dead and another is in custody after a
confrontation in a movie theater over
seating arrangements on June 25th
Witnesses told police that 19-year-old
Enrique Padilla entered the theater with
his girlfriend to see the film no hard
feelings Padilla confronted a couple who
were sitting in at least one of his
reserved seats the criminal complaint
says that theater staff tried to resolve
the issue but the dispute got physical a
bucket of popcorn was thrown shoving
ensued and eventually gunfire sending
moviegoers scrambling police said
52-year-old Michael tenorio was shot
twice and died at the scene Padilla is
facing charges of first-degree murder
shooting at an occupied building
conspiracy and tampering with evidence a
judge decided earlier this week that
Padilla will remain in custody until
trial
now if all this sounds very familiar you
might be thinking of a similar case last
year 79 year old Curtis Reeves stood
trial for shooting and killing a man in
2014 inside of a Wesley Chapel Florida
movie theater Reeves took the stand in
his own case saying that he shot 43 year
old Chad Olson in self-defense after
arguing over Olson texting during the
movie previews during the fight Reeves
said that Olson threw a bag of popcorn
at him prompting him to shoot Olsen he
was pronounced dead at the hospital
after being shot in the chest Olson's
wife also suffered a gunshot wound to
her hand Reeves who's a retired police
captain said that he was in fear of
being attacked his defense team put on
the case that at one point Olsen threw
his cell phone at Reeves's head
after just a few hours of deliberations
a jury acquitted Reeves of second-degree
murder and aggravated battery so Terry
the Padilla and the Reeves cases are
very similar very eerily similar you
think the outcome is going to be the
same I don't think it's going to be the
same because essentially we have two
different individuals in the Reeves case
he's an older gentleman and he said in
self-defense that he was essentially
afraid and he's the older man there was
a younger more fit person and this is
why he said he took his gun out now here
in this case Padilla essentially is
about the same age and he is not in any
way saying that you know he acted you
know he's saying he's acting in
self-defense but I think that it's going
to be a little bit harder he shot twice
whereas Curtis Reeves only shot once yes
Reeves wife was injured but it was with
the same bullet so I think it's going to
be hard for Badillo to say it was
self-defense I think he overreacted in
this case I think the jury is going to
think he overreacted and so shooting
twice is not defense you could have shot
once that would have taken care of the
threat if he really thought that he was
threatened so I think it's going to be a
different result well Brian the murder
in the first degree isn't that for
things like premeditated killings
planning can you make sense of the
charges that he's facing yeah so you
named it a lot of the Lesser included
charges the shooting occupied building
conspiracy in tampering with evidence
but I'll focus on that top one yes first
degree is typically the lying in weight
um depraved indifference whatever you
want to call it um premeditated but here
there's an actual type of first-degree
murder by an act that is greatly
dangerous to the lives of others showing
a depraved mind regardless of human life
because the pedia shot more than once in
a room where there are multiple people
they're saying it's not just dangerous
for that one individual but others and
that's why you're having the heightened
murder in the first degree that could
lead to Greater charges because not just
about hitting the person so making
others dangerous in that environment and
I'm glad you mentioned that because
sometimes first degree murder can be
different in different states and
clearly it is here Brian Terry thank you
so much everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
thank you